nous sommes allés à mairie de Coignières
avec le président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines pierre Bédié
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous venez de
signer un contrat Yvelines plus avec la
mairie de Coignières en quoi consiste ce
contrat alors c'est un contrat qui est
le contrat cadre que toutes les communes
du département peuvent demander au
département en l'espèce sur 5 millions
d'euros de dépenses la réflexion d'un
groupe scolaire un nouveau terrain enfin
la rénovation d'un terrain et une salle
une salle des fêtes
5 millions d'euros de dépenses le
département va subventionner de 1
million d'euros soit 20% de la dépense
j'imagine que le maire ira chercher
d'autres subventions ailleurs c'est une
façon pour les communes de pouvoir faire
plus grâce à l'aide du département en
quoi c'est important que le département
qu'il y ait cette solidarité entre les
collectivités parce que c'est notre âme
on a été créé pour ça lorsqu'elle a la
Révolution française on tous les
départements l'idée des constituants
c'est comme ils ont avant créer les
communes les communes seules sont
inégales il y a des grandes des petites
communes des communes d'andrées riches
d'autres dans des territoires pauvres et
donc en ayant un territoire plus vaste
plus large avec des revenus plus
importants et bien il pourra assurer une
certaine égalité entre ces communes
c'est la fonction du département donc on
remplit cette fonction j'ai la faiblesse
de pensée qu'on le fait un peu plus dans
les Yvelines que dans d'autres
départements puisque dans notre budget
d'investissement les subventions
d'investissement aux communes sont le
premier poste budgétaire c'est donc
notre priorité un premier poste
budgétaire d'être direct au Comines mais
il y a aussi des aides indirectes je
pense notamment peut-être à l'agence
ingénierie à l'agence activité qui
contribue indirectement
chaque fois qu'on peut apporter une aide
aux communes on le fait principalement
un investissement parce que c'est le
mode de gestion du département qui se
résume en une formule
surtout pour être généreux sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est
l'investissement parce que
l'investissement c'est pour les
générations actuelles et les générations
à venir et nous nous efforçons donc
chaque fois que c'est possible
d'apporter une aide aux communes comment
se fait le choix parce que je suppose
qu'il y a un peu plus de 200 communes
dans les Yvelines comment se fait le
choix parce qu'on peut pas distribuer à
tout le monde je suppose c'est toute la
difficulté d'exercice budgétaire il y a
259 communes et nous prévoyons une
enveloppe chaque année qui doit
correspondre à toutes les demandes qui
nous parviendront alors
s'il y a une année où on dépense un peu
plus bah on fera dans le cadre d'un
budget supplémentaire on abondera ce
budget investissement des communes
encore une fois c'est la priorité
on considère que les Yvelines sont le
département de la qualité de vie quand
on ne n'est pas yvelinois on a qu'une
envie c'est venir dans les Yvelines
surtout quand on habite la région
parisienne et pour parvenir à ça pour
être ce territoire de la qualité de vie
on peut pas le faire tout seul nous le
département il faut que les communes
soient engagées dans cette qualité de
vie et pour qu'elles puissent aussi
engager il faut une aide massive du
département c'est donc le sens de cette
politique alors pierre avec nous on va
juste écouter le maire de Coignières qui
va nous détailler justement les projets
qui vont être possible de rendre
possible
rendu possible avec cette aide que vous
lui attribuez la première opération
porte sur la rénovation de l'école
Bouvet alors c'est une rénovation
thermique importante de cette école
c'est la construction aussi d'un nouveau
restaurant scolaire et c'est aussi sa
mise au norme PMR le deuxième projet
c'est une ère multisport
intergénérationnel nous aurons donc deux
terrains de terrain de sport un terrain
de foot five un terrain de basket un
anneau donc d'athlétisme et puis du
street workout c'est à dire un espace de
musculation et puis enfin le rural qui
sera rénovée et qui deviendra un espace
associatif et culturel là dont tu as
besoin aujourd'hui la commune et
toujours à la mairie de Coignières avec
le président du conseil départemental
des Yvelines pierre Bédié vous lancez ce
lundi 7 novembre la tournée des cantons
le département et vous en quoi consiste
ce concept
l'idée c'est que surtout après cette
période un peu spéciale de covid de
confinement etc les liens se sont un peu
distendus on n'a pas forcément vu les
projets avancés on n'a pas eu le même
dialogue donc l'idée c'est resserrer ses
liens resserrer ses liens à l'intérieur
des Yvelines entre la commune et le
département entre les communes et le
département puis c'est l'occasion de
pouvoir voir des acteurs qu'on ne voit
pas autrement les élus on arrive à se
voir à travers un certain domaine de
manifestations mais on peut rencontrer
ça a été le cas lors du déjeuner des des
chefs d'entreprise des responsables
d'association sportive de commerce et
puis voir aussi le travail que font
certaines associations j'ai passé un
moment absolument formidable avec une
association qui lutte contre les
violences morales donc c'est une façon
de mieux connaître le territoire pour
mieux appréhender les problèmes de ce
territoire pour trouver les meilleures
solutions possibles je crois beaucoup à
ce dialogue direct
on fait mieux quand on est sur place sur
le terrain que quand on est enfermé dans
un bureau quel bilan concrètement vous
faites de cette journée quelle demande
vous avez eu disons dans cette prise de
température
il y a pas de bilan en ce sens que
il y avait pas de demande de particulier
mais
c'est un sentiment pour moi de profonde
satisfaction d'abord parce que venir
voir sur place on a vu avoisin des
sujets de circulation venir le voir de
ses propres yeux c'est quand même
toujours plus pertinent pour ma forme
d'intelligence que de regarder ça dans
une note que quelqu'un vous a rédigé
avec des plans et plus j'avoue que titre
personnel rencontrer rencontrer des
Yvelines noires engagés pour les
Yvelines heureux d'être dans les
Yvelines c'est bon pour le moral donc on
recommencera merci Pierre Bédié Merci à
VOUS président du conseil départemental
des Yvelines qui va poursuivre cette
tournée des cantons dans les prochaines
semaines